you also I did we're at we're at
surprise but I did go to Sopranos Konya
yeah well I'm anxious to hear you did we
do repeat a little bit did we take any
of your steam with your dad's well I
mean Furio does make a brief appearance
so there's that okay
so luckily every time Mike goes out on
the street we do it on video yeah and
that's an added benefit to those with
the Sirius XM app you can watch these
whole things but Mike it would appear
that you are dressed as The Godfather
yes it looks like you got a bowtie it's
like a like a bit of a poor man's tuxedo
but a tuxedo nonetheless amazon.com yes
okay you are holding a cat much like
Marlon Brando's was able to pet in the
Godfather movie I am the God [ __ ] your
hair is slicked back do you have a
little stuffed puffed in your cheeks
ideas through some cotton balls in the
conv all's in the cheeks and as you know
since you're The Godfather and
everything you're standing in front of a
picture of Tony Soprano yes did anybody
comment on the fact that you might have
been confusing characters or prising
leaf you but you know Mike it is one
favorite of this show when you talk to
people in costumes and they and you you
expect them to maintain the character oh
absolutely yeah we kind of disappeared
on us there for a while you want to let
us know what happened I had to go back
home my mother was very ill I did go
back home and see my mother yeah yes it
didn't have anything to do with your
feelings for a certain lady I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
actually I have no idea who she used to
make you coffee and you'd bring her
pastry Nadja manager we are good to
friends it's no big deal
so we got a big Mets fan here sherry are
talking about Carmela yeah yeah really
good that was him yeah it's like being
there and for those of you wondering why
Mike the Mike monotones voice is not
quite as clear as it usually is it's
because he's got cotton balls
[Laughter]
okay now you're interviewing a guy in a
Metz coat and a Mets hat that looks like
the Apple that pops out yeah he was
confused as to what day it was
I see long suffering I would I don't
know if it's really that much suffering
it's far enough though go out there and
play so it's not really like who do you
have a favorite character it's good
question I like I like a phil leotardo
you have a favorite phil leotardo moment
the probably the part the one where you
know where he does a speech about or he
doesn't speech about how he gets
considerably worse all right how did he
not get Oh long-suffering fan it's like
a jovial thing you say to a guy at a bar
and he's like well you know I don't
actually play for the Mets so oh okay
thanks man thanks for clearing that up
you know what I love Mike didn't take
the tag off his cat I noticed that I
noticed that too are we thinking about a
return ski on that item no I'm gonna
keep it then you realize I was there oh
yeah you are it's also you unfortunately
had the cat facing tag side to the
camera fourth wall just crumbles feel
free to stay in character the entire
time that mr. gaultieri
what brings you Sopranos this is my home
this New Jersey is the Meadowlands is
where I belong this is where you belong
some bodies out here
you buried somebody how many bodies you
got out here at this point it's around
400 around for dude just Paulie walnuts
just confess to you on camera that he
had murdered 400 people in New Jersey
alone he's dressed like a Dick Tracy
villain yeah he couldn't look anything
less like Paulie walnuts very very
surprised that you got that correct
he is the most prolific murderer in
American history 400 kills all buried in
the Meadowlands right underneath the
Continental Arena Wow
just that literally is the foundation
that's amazing so it's good that you
gave them the information that feel free
to stay in character the one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app